thank you guys here with Lanier
Dominguez you drew today but you must
have felt that you had him yeah I mean I
felt that I had a huge advantage of
course after the opening it was so nice
but I mean he kept playing fast and I at
some point uh of course I missed this
move Bishop G5 but I felt that I should
have something very strong there but I
just couldn't find it I was calculating
and wasting all my time and I didn't
really see the killing blow I mean I was
looking here at Knight C4 but it doesn't
work it seems to me uh no you played
this Rook C4 yeah Knight C5
takes yeah and after Bishop D2 I mean I
saw Bishop D6
Queen C4 Queen B7 and then something
like King G6
takes on f8 Rook C7
I just didn't look clear to me uh
um he wants to play Queen E2 maybe next
or something like that also King Y8 I
mean instead of King G6
okay let me go back a little bit
yeah we analyzed this position actually
on air
um
I I gotta ask well what did you think
was unclear about let's say the queen
before or something along those lines
well Queenie two Rook F1
um
yeah maybe like this Rook of sun Bishop
C5 yeah very solid yeah
yeah no I felt that it should be winning
of course but I I mean he played so
quickly and I didn't really
um I I just wasn't sure that this was
winning and uh yeah I went for the
safest option but uh of course position
is so bad for plug that there should be
a win do you think that psychology
influenced you a lot today he was
playing so fast and you were playing so
slow that your mind started believing
your opponent yeah I mean it's uh but on
the other hand he it's it's not that he
played like this just in this game I
mean he just plays like this in general
so of course it's uh not the most
pleasant experience when you're thinking
thinking and your opponents just
blitzing out all the moves
um but uh yeah that's that's what it is
yeah so how do you feel after this game
you did play Slow you got on time
pressure do you feel that you should
have wanted or do you feel well it's
just a game of trust me no of course
yeah it's uh I should have won but uh
it's you know it's normal I mean
um I
I think that you shouldn't make such a
big deal of uh any result in chess I
mean just uh there are so many mistakes
and missed opportunities and sometimes
you uh Escape like yesterday so it's
it's just fine I mean you have to to
take it easy and just to think about the
next game take it easy and be happy then
here three rounds so far in this
tournament how do you feel your
performance has been yeah well uh I
think I
I haven't played so badly I mean even
even in the in the rabbit and Blitz I
didn't think I'd play so terrible it's
just uh I was yeah the result was just
terrible but my play wasn't necessarily
that bad and I think uh in the classical
um yeah I'm doing uh reasonable
reasonably well for for the moment so
but let's see what uh what happens well
thank you for joining us here Lanier
we'll let you go it's plenty of
tournament left and good luck for those
rounds thank you
linear indeed and let's just check